[Music]
hi
this is lori calling from cambridge
massachusetts i just
finished listening to your audiobook
stories that i only tell my friends and
i
actually really enjoyed it um not so
happy
uh listening to the f-bomb but that's
just a stylistic thing i think you're a
great writer
and i'm interested in knowing what is
your process or has been your process
for writing both
books stories plays scripts that kind of
thing
are you a person who gets up early every
day
you write a certain amount and take some
breaks or
how do you stay motivated to do your
writing and meanwhile keep it up you
always enjoyed your or
in your work and you seem like a sparkly
happy person and great great
um to hear about a family
that is so well connected as yours has
been and continues to be
thanks so much bye oh thank you so much
i like that thank you um well
you know um it's funny that i asked
my heroes my writer friends the same
thing you did i'm fascinated
with people's process of writing whether
it's songs or books or
and everyone has something that works
for them i mean stephen king
famously he has a you know
super duper regimen in writes i think i
think he writes eight pages a day no
matter
what no matter what which is
mind-blowing
i am not so disciplined probably why i'm
not as good a writer as stephen king
but i think of it as this way the muse
inspiration is always in the drawer of
your desk
and sometimes the drawer is open
sometimes open for a long time and
sometimes it's closed
and won't open but you're never going to
know what's going to happen unless
you're at the desk
so um i'm under no illusion about
writer's block
i'm only going to get past it if i'm
sitting with my pad and paper it isn't
going to happen
taking a walk or clearing my head or
doing yoga
um the muse will happen when you have
your
instrument in your hand um i write
anywhere anytime
um i love being on planes because i'm
uninterrupted i've written a ton on
planes
trains and cars
i've written on my lunch breaks on sets
um
i kind of find it really interesting to
see how many different places i can
write in i do not have a dedicated
writing space although i do have a
favorite area in my house
and i'm also a big fan of deadlines i
i love having a deadline a lot of people
don't i've never missed a deadline
because i've always been a pleasure to
have in class
and grades weren't so good but i was
always a pleasure to have in class
so if you give me a deadline i'm going
to deliver for you so again thank you
and thank you for reading
for reading the books and the next books
no f-bombs
i promise